[Music]
the Republicans now control the federal
government they control some 25 to 30
state governments the Democrats far
fewer and so they've been sitting on an
agenda and actually I think most of them
didn't think Trump would win the
presidency and when he did there so for
them it's a opportunity to pass what's
been on their agenda which is deregulate
stuff tax cuts changed the affordable
care act so they want that to happen and
but all these things that happen with
Trump national security Flynn the
Russians that's all a distraction for
them and they're there they're under
sort of dual pressure they want to get
their agenda through and they have to
have the president with them to get that
through but they're under pressure on
the other hand too well what are we
going to do about the Russia connection
etc at what point the Republicans in
Congress make a break and on what do
they make the break and I think that's
not likely to happen in the short run
because they need the president to get
the they get to tax cuts that they want
through especially corporate tax cuts
they want that gain capital gains they
want that reduce so I think they're
waiting to get that thrill and then
we'll see the courts are still relevant
actor but the most relevant actors to
Congress and the Democrats in Congress
are already pretty clear where they are
so the question is over time what's the
likelihood that the Republican Party a
Republican Party in the Congress is
willing to steps up not willing to good
steps up and says no more of this this
and not this they want the tax code
change they want regulation to go down
they now own the Affordable Care Act
which I think is going to be harder for
them to solve then they might have
thought it was because I don't think
they can afford to have very many people
go uncovered
because then the precedent Democrats
will beat him and it's not a good issue
going into the midterm in the 2020
election if I were the Democrats I would
say you know the identity politics is
okay but you've carried it too far in
the process of the identity politics
you forgot about all those people in the
Midwest who you have lost jobs and so on
and so forth you can't you can't forget
those people and I think that's even
more important because if when you talk
about jobs leaving what this artificial
intelligence is going to seems to me
over the next 10-15 years create it's
going to create a problem why well I
mean you think of the gig economy over
lyft Mercedes Benz for GM they're all
trying to get cars and trucks that drive
themselves well guess who drives those
and if you're a truck driver in America
you can make a pretty good income you
make seventy eighty ninety a hundred
thousand dollars a year doing that those
jobs are gone that's even more of a
problem for those areas that you didn't
win the last time so you got it you got
to start thinking about them and you
gotta start saying yeah I don't think
you have to abandon the other but you
have to figure out a way to put the yet
to figure out a way to put the put the
two of them together and and then then
they'll be alright but that's not going
to be that's not going to be
particularly easy and I don't worry even
so much about jobs actually well I were
in lot of buzz wages or jobs created
what are they going to pay my father was
able to raise a family
six children with a factory job in the
Midwest and he was able to do that you
know we were at rich but you know we had
we did we had a hot we had a home not we
known it but we had a roof over our
heads and we were fed all the time when
we had clothes and we went to school we
and all those things and so I worry
about wages because
out of these wages you people can no
longer afford that I think their main
problem is a demographic problem so on
the social issues that they take these
positions on if you look at the age
range people over 65 they're with the
Republicans than 55 to 65 they're sort
of mixed on but after that 45 to 55
they're against by the time you get down
to people 25 or more they are just
totally against it they don't care about
issues like gay marriage they don't they
don't care about those sorts of things
they're they're irrelevant to them and
and some in some ways colleague Peter
Berkowitz talked about the Republicans
have got to forget about trying to
repeal the sex sexual revolution and
they some time still time that's not
going to happen I assure you that is not
going to happen just talk to young
pianist and whether they get it look at
their own kids you can see that that's
not working so they need to figure out
how they're going to deal with that
long-run demographic problem and also
probably how are they going to handle
Hispanic voters
[Music]
the question you hear out here all the
time is well can he last for years the
answer is sure he can
but for me the more important question
is can he be effective and in my view
hasn't shown that he can be because
being effective means I want the
following policy changes I want a change
I want be saying and change that I want
see change you have to bring people
together some of you have to get through
the Congress some of them you have to
get the bureaucrats to agree to it some
of you have to get the courts to agree
to it and in all ways you have to
coordinate it and get it through the
system and in most cases its Congress
and the bureaucracy both have to be with
you in the change so the question is is
he are he and the Republican Party in
the Congress capable are they able to do
that so I'm looking to see how those
things balance out and and and that that
means I have to sort of judge the
president's behavior and you have to
judge the Congress behavior so that's
what I'm watching the interaction
between the Congress and the president
[Music]